joke eh this is very strong
me in other words
I think the strongest thing that has happened with this album.
I think it was this song
because this is the 4th time I sing in Basque
and this is the 4th time I sing in Basque.
is a well known song there
Salvador Ren eriot Sean
which is a mourning song
and that it is sung a lot there
I knew I was singing an important song
but not so much
now I think I understand what it means that someone
of the Spanish state
sings
a song in Basque for everything that happened
what has happened with the Basque language
for so many years
I am from the lopse,
not I am from 86.
I was not told many things
now I have many friends Basque friends
of course that
who were persecuted for speaking Basque
and and being one of the oldest languages in the world.
I mean,
it looks like a jewel to me
it seems to me as
open a drawer and say but if this is a treasure
a brutal treasure
is one of the most listened songs on the album.
is that besides,
the beautiful thing is that there are things that are
there are concepts that exist in these languages
that do not exist in Spanish
is that it amazes me
it amazes me that at some point someone
eh pursue something so valuable
that's what I don't understand